it's like CSI we can solve these crime
scenes only our crime happened 145
million years ago
you have Allosaurus the predator and you
have Sulawesi ax the herbivore and
they're both found only yards away from
each other so there's a story there that
we haven't quite unlocked yet my name is
Jason Poole my favorite dinosaur is
probably serratus horas right now it's a
really cool looking carnivore with a
thing on its nose a little horn on its
nose they're not like everybody else's
favorite as t-rex which is kind of
Awesome my favorite but I probably have
like five favorites silly question I
love dinosaurs a hundred and forty five
million years ago the area is flat so
every time you had a flooding event
quite a few animals that would have just
dead across the flat plains and every
season the rains would happen and it
buries everything
the whole reason that we come out to
Montana and Wyoming is to find a place
that preserves fossils well so a little
bit earlier
one of our volunteers uncovered this
root of this great bone you see it's
sort of a little bit darker than what
it's laying in in three weeks we're
really trying to accomplish as much as
possible so that means we have to get
rid of stuff that's just gonna slow us
down paleontology has been done the same
way for the last 150 years but data
capture has evolved platforms like this
allow us to share this data immediately
that helps us understand the areas that
we're working on we gather so the bands
or computers in general just it's
amazing how much they speed things up
you're able to very quickly adapt to new
possibilities that's what we have to be
all about it we work with an awful lot
of students a lot of young people
getting them interested in science in
general is awesome being outdoors and
doing science is even awesome
I started working at became natural
sciences in Philadelphia when I was 16
so it's really Jason's fault that I
became a doctor in it and will continue
for the rest of my life classes are nice
they like fossils
technology moves forward and it's going
to drag our fossils with it
paleontology in general as a science
takes a lot of creativity drawing and
painting is sort of almost an escape for
me so it's it's dealing with my
obsession we should deal with all day at
work but in a different way it just
helps me to see the bigger picture
things start to fall into place then you
get to these answers and hopefully those
answers just give you more questions of
course most of the clues have been gone
for 65 million years
that's awesome
you